the discriminant is this part right here
in the quadratic formula the b squared
minus 4ac so without doing the entire
quadratic formula you can zero in that
just on this quantity here b squared
minus 4ac without the square root and
you can find out the nature of the roots
or the number of solutions that the
quadratic formula will have and so the
way you would do that is you calculate
what b squared minus 4ac is okay and
just keep in mind that this is in the
form ax squared plus BX plus C equals 0
so the a is the coefficient front of the
x squared term the B is the coefficient
in front of the X term and then the C is
the constant make sure everything is on
one side and it's set equal to zero but
when you calculate this if it's greater
than zero meaning that it's positive you
then want to evaluate is it a perfect
square like 4 9 16 25 36 if it is then
you're going to have two real rational
solutions if it's not a perfect square
you're going to have two real solutions
but they're going to be irrational
meaning like square roots that you can't
simplify like square root of 17 or
square root of 21 now if it comes out to
0 you just get one real solution and the
reason is is if this is 0 whether you
add 0 or you subtract 0 this quantity is
you know cancelling out you're just
gonna have B over 2a now this is called
a repeated root okay and what that means
is that if you were to factor the
quadratic you would get the same
solution twice okay and then the third
case is that b squared minus 4ac is less
than 0 meaning it's negative this
quantity underneath the square root
would be negative when you take the
square root of a negative number
that's where you get the imaginary
solutions or what they call it complex
solutions and you're going to get two of
those negative B plus that quantity
negative B minus that quantity so let's
get right into these examples and we'll
take a look at how it works so in this
example you can see that a is 1 B is
positive 5 and C is 4 so if we do our b
squared minus 4ac what do we get B
squared is 5 squared which is 25 minus 4
times a which is 1 times 4 which is the
C value so this comes out to 25 minus 16
which equals 9 and you can see that 9 is
greater than 0 it's positive and it's a
perfect square so we get two real
rational solutions okay so now we're not
actually solving for what the solutions
are at this point
we're just figuring out what's the type
of solution and how many okay so the
next example we've got b squared minus
4ac okay so let's write that down so b
squared would be negative 6 squared
minus 4 times a which is 1 okay times C
which is 1 and you get 36 minus 4 which
is 32 now notice that 32 is positive
meaning greater than 0 but it's not a
perfect square so we're getting 2 real
but they're irrational solutions so two
of them but irrational this one here
we've got B squared which is 4 squared
minus 4 times a times C which gives us
16 minus 16 which equals 0 so you can
see here that's this case here we have
one real solution but it's a repeated
solution what that means is that if you
were to graph this parabola okay this
isn't the exact graph but basically what
it's going to do is just going to touch
the x-axis just at one point and that
points going to be the vertex okay so
then the last case here we're going to
do b squared minus 4ac again so 2
squared minus 4 times 3 times 2 that's 4
minus 24 which gives us a negative 20
now notice this is less than 0 that's
this last case here which means we're
going to get two imaginary solutions or
what you call complex solution